Elon Musk has painted this world of
electric cars that can drive themselves
but if he couldn't keep the company
afloat then was Tesla going to be able
to survive long enough for Elon Musk to
deliver this vision less than a year ago
things looked bleak for Tesla when
shares dropped below $200 but in just
seven short months CEO Elon Musk has
turned the company into the most
valuable US automaker of all time so how
did the embattled founder get back to
delivering the impossible for his
shareholders 2017 and 2018 were largely
a trip through hell for Elon Musk and
Tesla things didn't work out as planned
boring bonehead questions are not cool
next backhoe and marijuana in there
that's all it is today the SEC filed
securities fraud charges against Elon
Musk
stemming from his August 7th 2018
statements that he was considering
taking Tesla private these image
problems for musk were compounded by
production issues for Tesla Model 3
deliveries were delayed and the promised
$35,000 price tag was never met he had
very ambitious targets to build the
model 3 compact car in California and it
turned out way harder than you expected
in part because of Elon Musk's vision
for automation he talked about an idea
of being able to turn the lights off and
let the robots do their work well the
plan and the vision will turn out to be
much more complicated than anyone
anticipated or at least he anticipated
then on day one of 2019 US customers
were hit with an effective price
increase to buy any Tesla the federal
tax credit for electric vehicles was cut
in half as part of a planned year-long
phase-out the company announced it was
lowering the vehicles price because it
was essentially trying to counteract
that effective price increase some took
that is a sign that Tesla perhaps had
peaked at the number of customers in the
u.s. willing or able to afford that
higher priced Model 3
a week later Tesla started construction
of a new factory in China the country's
first entirely foreign owned car plant
without any local partners China's the
world's largest auto market huge
consumer of electric vehicles and luxury
vehicles so in a lot of ways of really
good place for Tesla to play you on
promise that by the end of the year the
factory will be up and running and
they'd be building cars that's a
remarkable promise to make and a lot of
close auto industry observers really
question if that was going to be
possible thinking that perhaps this was
yet again another overly ambitious
target that Elon Musk was setting for
the company and that in reality would
probably take much longer first quarter
sales were worse than expected beginning
the year with a loss just months after
musk ensured shareholders that Tesla
would be profitable every quarter into
the future short of a disaster analysts
looked at it and they really began to
wonder what the demand level was like
here in the US some of the older
vehicles like the Model S and the Model
X had been the underpinning of the
company's business and if demand was
falling off for those vehicles that
would raise questions about kind of the
financial house that Tesla had built the
stock continued to fall and in early
June
Tesla closed at just under a hundred and
seventy nine dollars per share the
company's lowest closing price of 2019
so the third quarter we're starting to
see the fruits of Tesla's labor they'd
been working to get the model threes to
Europe and into China and a turning
point for Tesla in 2019 was really the
announcement of a surprise profit and
the company started looking like well
maybe there maybe they are on the right
track and returned to a story of
potential growth at the end of November
must prevailed Tesla's long-awaited
cyber truck the world's first electric
pickup truck doesn't look like anything
else as the event began to unfold they
were talking about features that really
you don't normally talk about in a in a
new car such as windows that were
bulletproof and so on stage Elon and his
people were making a demonstration of
this and they got these metal balls sure
yeah oh my god this is like unheard of
you don't really don't see a CEO on
stage with such a colossal demonstration
gone awry so the next day you might
think the stock might go down but in
fact you're seeing huge conversations
about this vehicle just days later Musk
tweeted that more than two hundred and
fifty thousand people had placed
pre-orders for a cyber truck from there
something interesting happened it
returned the conversation to the future
of Tesla it was always what had they
done today and why were they struggling
to get these cars out and and what musk
has had been able to do is just put the
conversation yet again to this new
vision of what he was promising for
personal transportation exactly a year
after breaking ground at the Shanghai
factory Tesla held a press conference to
announce their first deliveries of China
made model threes to Chinese customers
the car maker also confirmed it had met
another of Musk's seemingly impossible
goals delivering at least 360,000
electric vehicles in 2019 the surprise
here was that Elon delivered on what
he'd promised something that he'd
struggled in the past but here he was
executing something that really enthused
investors because if he could deliver on
these promises what other promises could
he deliver on Tesla just reported
another profitable quarter but the
future is still uncertain the company
has yet to deliver a full-year profit
and it's unclear how long success in
China will last the entire Chinese car
market has been falling steadily for two
years and demand for electric vehicles
has declined the past few months there's
a still question about whether Tesla got
into China a little bit too late if the
party might be over so one of the things
that Tesla is going to face here in
coming months is what's the demand for
its vehicles
you